[MUSIC PLAYING]
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Hi, everybody.
My name is Yuri.
I'm a Cloud Customer Engineer
based here in San Francisco.
I'm focused on Google
Cloud reliability.
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Anthony Bushong.
And I'm a Customer
Engineer Specialist
focused on Kubernetes.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Awesome.
All right, so let's get into it.
So this is us.
So the first thing-- and
I'm sure that if you've been
in this lounge all day,
or you've seen any other
presentations, you've probably
seen this any number of times--
but since we're
going to be talking
about putting Site Reliability
Engineering, or SRE principles,
into practice, the first
thing we should talk about
is, what is Site
Reliability Engineering
and what are the principles?
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Yeah,
probably a good place to start.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, all right, so--
Anthony, this may
be your background.
But I think sort of
the purpose of SRE
is to solve some of
the tensions that
arise in the
product-development lifecycle.
So can you tell, me how does
Agile play into it first?
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Yeah, I mean, I think
this is something where a lot
of the digital transformation,
probably within the past decade,
has been focused around Agile.
And I think a co-worker
for me summed it
up best, where Scrum is
too Agile as SRE is DevOps.
And so Agile is
largely focused on
of breaking down barriers
between product management,
product development,
and actual software
engineering and developers.
But on the other side
of the coin, and this
is where it becomes
relevant for SREs,
is how do we build
reliable services?
And a lot of folks
stand by the notion
that that requires breaking down
similar walls between developer
and operations, IT operations.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Exactly.
So that's DevOps is
intended to do, right?
DevOps is intended to bring
development operations
together, give them a
common incentive model,
stop them from
fighting, eliminate
that wall of confusion where
you throw code over the wall
and hope it works out.
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Right, and ultimately,
just to get to market
faster requires both
of these types of practices.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Absolutely.
All right, so SRE, or Site
Reliability Engineering,
is essentially a
specific implementation,
or a specific set of practices,
that we here at Google
have found that
really enable this.
And there are five key areas.
So it's about reducing
organizational silos,
operating with failure
as a normal outcome,
implementing changes
gradually in an automated way,
and finally making all
decisions data driven,
and measuring everything.
So at a high level,
that's what SRE is.
All right?
Now, what are the principles of
Site Reliability Engineering?
If you've read the
SRE book, and I
see we have at least one
copy of it on the back shelf,
I think that maybe
there are more--
I don't know if those
are for grabbing or not.
But maybe we'll just say--
no, they're not!
All right, don't grab that copy.
It's only for display.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Set design.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah.
So the SRE principles that we'll
focus on for this specific talk
are, first, service
levels, and error budgets.
And if you saw the
previous talk, some of that
should be familiar to you.
And then we'll talk
about observability.
And finally, we'll get
into release engineering.
All right?
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Yeah, sounds good.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All right.
So let's start by talking
about service levels and error
budgets.
So this is a kind of famous
line that in some ways,
I think, underpins a lot
of what SRE is all about.
And that is that 100%
is the wrong reliability
target for everything.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Yeah.
We have a couple of posters.
But I am curious to hear.
So you explain a little
bit about the methodology
or the understanding
behind that?
Why isn't it a good
target for reliability?
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, a good question.
At a very fundamental level--
because there's no point
in delivering a service
that's 100% reliable.
Because your users will never
experience 100% reliability.
The methods that they use
to connect and consume
your service are
not 100% reliable.
And they never will be.
You've all got phones.
You all use mobile networks.
You all use the Wi-Fi
at the conference.
None of that stuff
is 100% reliable.
So what is the point of
running a service 100% reliable
that users will
never benefit from?
The second thing is, the
only way you actually
achieve 100% reliability,
is to eliminate all changes.
Change is risk.
Risk means failure,
means downtime.
So the only way you prevent
any downtime or any performance
issues is by removing
all change, which means
you can never do anything.
You can never build anything.
You can never advance the
service in any meaningful way.
So that's why 100%
is the wrong target.
OK?
So then if 100% percent
is the wrong target,
what is the right target?
What is the Service
Level Objective
that your service
should deliver on?
And conversely, what do you
do with that gap between 100%
and your actual SLO, right?
Then that's the error budget.
And the big thing
that I think is often
lost in this
conversation of SLOs
and error budgets is the idea
that error budgets actually
allow you to increase velocity.
Service Level Objectives, and
strictly adhering to them,
is not just a way to prevent
developers from doing stuff.
If at the end of the month, or
at the end of the SLO window,
whatever it may
be, yet you still
have error budget
available, that's
actually an opportunity for your
developers to do more stuff.
It's room to experiment.
They can experiment with
the code, experiment
with flags and
features, experiment
with the infrastructure,
and config management.
All of that is enabled by having
development and operations,
or Site Reliability
Engineering, align
on a common principle of
operating from an error budget.
So then the next
obvious question
is, all right, that
all sounds good.
We all agree.
SLOs are the way to go.
But we're here today to
talk about putting them
into practice, especially
with Stackdriver.
So how do we do this?
Well, what we want to do
is to actually configure
monitoring for
SLOs in Stackdriver
so that we can actually
measure and make sure
that we are, in fact,
delivering on the promises
that we made to our users
in the Service Level
Objective, or the SLO.
And then we want an alert
on both SLO violations,
but also increases
in error budget
burn rate, that let us know when
an outage or an SLO violation
might actually be pending.
So what is that
going to look like?
I'm going to stop the
slide deck for a second.
And here, we're going to get
into some of the new stuff that
was actually announced,
basically, in a letter today.
You saw the keynote.
You saw Anthos as one
of the announcements.
One of the key components
is the Cloud Service Mesh,
or the Anthos Service Mesh.
What this is going
to allow us to do
is actually expose all
of the services that
are now running in our
project for any given service.
For example, this
product-page service,
I can get details for it.
Let's see how good the--
speaking a reliable Wi-Fis.
That's not bad.
We can go to the-- ah,
well, there you go.
We are having a reliability
issue with our service
reliability monitoring.
We can get into the service.
We can understand what's
actually going on there.
We can set SLOs.
And from there, we can actually
set a learning policies
on SLO violations that will
take us into Stackdriver.
So now, we have the ability to
monitor service health directly
within the Cloud Console.
We have the ability to set
SLOs against those services,
and actually configure alerting
and notifications on not just
network thresholds the way that
alerting policies have enabled
us to do for years
at this point,
but actual SLO
violations, all right.
So that's really kind of
the first SRE principle
that we want to cover, which
is all about operating off
SLOs, not just metric
thresholds, and then
configure alerting for
those in Stackdriver.
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
And ultimately, this
brings us closer to a
user-first mindset, right?
Because ultimately, the
user isn't seeing directly
CP utilization.
But they are certainly
seeing whatever
you are defining as your
service-level objective.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah, exactly.
All right, so let's move on to
our second principle, which is
all about observability, right?
So what is observability?
Well, it's just
monitoring repackaged.
I'm quoting someone here
who is a lot smarter than I
am and knows a lot
more about this.
Cindy literally wrote
the book on monitoring
distributed systems.
If you haven't read
it, you should.
It's really good.
And she like, I said,
knows this stuff a lot
more than either one of us do.
But essentially, observability
is the combination
of what we often refer to as the
golden signals, metrics, logs,
and traces.
So a logical question might be,
well, why do we need all that?
What does all of that do?
Well, I'll start by
talking about metrics.
Metrics are a way
to really understand
the health of our system, and
the health of the components
in our system, over time.
Because they represent
the movement of specific
values, again,
against a time scale.
And if the question
is, all right,
there are lots of metrics, what
should we really pay attention
to?
Fundamentally, there are really
three; traffic, how much stuff
is happening; latency, how
fast stuff is happening;
and errors, are our
users actually able to do
what they need to do.
If you can add saturation
to that, which is really
just a way to
understand, basically,
our ability to deliver against
our capacity, that's great.
Because that's the
first place you
can look at to
understand whether or not
issues with your
service have to do
with running out of capacity.
But fundamentally,
that's really what
you need in order to understand
the health of your system.
So how do you get
metrics in Stackdriver?
Where do they come from?
Well, if you're running
on NGCP, if you're easy
managed GCP resources,
and all of that stuff
is an instrument for you
right out of the box.
So if you go to Stackdriver,
you go to the resources section,
there's an entire GCP area
that shows you the metrics
for all the various
GCP managed services.
So for example,
something like Pub/Sub,
it builds your dashboard
out of the box.
You can see metric.
You can see information
all right in there.
It allows to create
a learning policy.
If you need it, again,
it's Pub/Sub resources.
You can obviously
filter the information
by a specific resource if
you want to filter it down
to a specific Pub/Sub topic.
The other thing you
should be aware of
is this idea of
transparent SLIs.
This is a relatively new
addition to Stackdriver.
But it actually allows
you to include SLI signals
from the platform in your
own reporting and alerting,
even if you so choose.
So transparent SLIs give
you latency, error rate,
and traffic data for
Google Platform APIs.
So if you want to see like what
the latency is of the Compute
API within you're
within your project
or any of the other APIs that
you're actually relying on,
you can now include these
signals in your own dashboards,
correlate them with signals
that are being emitted
from your own
applications or services,
and really quickly understand
whether a problem that you're
observing has to do with your
code or something on our side.
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
And so this might
be really useful
in scenarios where
we're adopting a
mutable infrastructure,
rolling out new changes
that is dependent upon some
of these platform APIs.
And so we want to look at
that in kind of conjunction
with our environment.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Exactly,
yeah, very much so.
If you're running a
computer infrastructure
in GCP, specifically,
[INAUDIBLE]
Compute Engine Instances,
metrics from those
are created automatically
when you first just spin up
the instances.
You get basic metrics
like CPU, disk IO,
and network throughput,
just, again, out of the box,
automatically.
You also have the option of
installing the Stackdriver
Monitoring Agent
on those instances
to both capture
additional information,
like memory, for example.
Lots of additional
metrics also get created
when you install the agent.
And finally, you get a
process-level monitoring.
You can actually
see whether or not
a particular process
on your instance
is running, how much
resources it's consuming.
And then you can create you
know alerting and things
like that against that process,
as well, if you so choose.
So there's a lot of value to
using the monitoring agent.
And finally, just a kind of
quick dive into custom metrics.
Let's right let's
say that you want
to emit specific information
from within your application.
You have a few options there.
Your first option is to actually
use the Stackdriver Monitoring
API directly.
The big advantage of doing that
is that gives you full control.
You control exactly against
which resources the metrics
were written against, how
often they're written,
what the labels are,
all that sort of thing.
The big trade off,
obviously, is complexity.
You have to manage
all of that stuff.
Your second option
is to use OpenCensus,
which is a library that
does both distributed
tracing and the metric
instrumentation for a subset
of languages that it supports.
And that's the big advantage.
You can actually
use a single library
to do both tracing and
metric instrumentation.
The big sort of trade there
is that the language support
is a little bit uneven.
Not every language that
opens has the support.
Supports, today,
will actually let
you do both traces the metrics.
So you kind of have to
look at what are you
writing your application
in and what can you do.
And then the last
option is Prometheus.
So this is an open-source
monitoring tool.
Lots of you may be
familiar with it.
I saw someone here earlier
with Prometheus shirt on.
It gives you
additional visibility
into the infrastructure that
the Prometheus, basically,
instrumentation is running on.
The big off there
is that, if you
want Prometheus metrics to
show up and Stackdriver,
the only way that works today
is if you have Prometheus
running in Kubernetes.
So if you install it
on the GKE cluster,
and then patch that deployment
with a Stackdriver collector,
you can ingest those
metrics into Stackdriver.
So the last part
about Prometheus
is that it allows
you to ingest--
you can ingest Prometheus
metrics into Stackdriver.
But the only way you can
do that is if Prometheus
is running in Kubernetes.
Because then you can patch
that Prometheus deployment
with a Stackdriver Collector
and ingest those metrics
into Stackdriver.
So the second kind of signals
we're talking about is logs.
So logs are very much
events, what happened
at a specific point in time.
They can be structured.
They can be very unstructured,
as we've learned when
we try to build some demos.
Sometimes you get
a log entry that's
just one massive line of text.
And then you don't know
what to do with it.
So there's lots of places
where they come from.
There's lots of data to store.
There are a few different ways
to get logs into Stackdriver.
Logging, obviously all
of the GCP services emit
logs natively.
There's nothing you
need to do there.
There's no setup at all.
For your services, we
have client libraries
force Stackdriver logging
that you can use to, again,
send logs to Stackdriver.
And then, as you're
running on Kubernetes,
you can use Fluentd
to basically just
have your containers write logs
to Standard Out or Stand Error.
And then Fluentd will
just ingest those logs
and send them to the
Stackdriver backend.
And finally, traces, so
traces are all about latency,
especially understanding
service-to-service
communication latency
in distributed systems.
So this is
highly-structured data.
They're made up of
spans and child spans.
One trace is scoped
to a specific request.
And a few examples
of how you use
tracing to get this
data into Stackdriver,
so the first option is you
can use the Trace Agent.
So this is something
you literally just
include in your code.
You put it in as the very
sort of the top of the file.
And it'll trace all
the requests in and out
of that particular service.
The big advantage of using
the Stackdriver Trace Agent
is that it's really easy,
literally one line of code.
The big trade off of
using it is that it
doesn't give you any control.
So you can't actually
manually create spans--
or you can't manually
create traces of spans.
It'll just do tracing for you.
Your second option
is, again, OpenCensus.
So we talked about
at the beginning.
It gives you a lot more control.
The big trade off
there is complexity.
And then your third
option is OpenTracing,
which is another
open-source tracing library.
The trade off of OpenTracing
is that it only does tracing.
It does not do both
tracing and metrics.
The way that OpenCensus does.
However--
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Yeah,
so how do people--
I mean, it seems like there's
a couple distinct libraries,
OpenCensus, OpenTracing.
How do you folks actually
navigate that space?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah,
that's a great question.
And the good news
there is that we're--
not "we."
These two projects
are actually merging.
So here's the link
to the Medium post
that you can see
in the deck here.
And you can find this
on Medium pretty easily.
But OpenTracing and OpenCensus
are actually going to merge.
So there will really be
just a single open-source
tracing library that
you'll be able to use.
I don't think this is
going to happen tomorrow.
But this is very
much the direction
of these two projects.
And I say this as a sort
of an outside observer.
I'm not, myself, a member
of either these projects.
All right, so to kind of wrap
up this particular section,
the observability,
or the ability
to understand what is
happening in your system
is really the combination of
three major signals, metrics,
logs, and traces.
Stackdriver gives
you a common backend
to collect all that information.
We've talked about
some of the options
that you could use to do so.
And, yeah, you should do that.
It gives you much
good information
that you can use
during incidents
to do troubleshooting.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: And I
think, just anecdotally,
from my perspective, some
of the exciting stuff
about Stackdriver specifically
is seeing folks come in,
standardizing on
Prometheus, and being
able to see that there
is that integration.
But there's also,
on the flip side,
a lot of native integration
just into those GCP resources,
almost a no-opt to set up.
So--
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
All right, so now,
let's talk about
a third principle,
which is release engineering.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: All right, so
I'm going to use this switch.
It should look the
same if it worked.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: There it is.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: There it is.
All right, cool.
So the last SRE principle that
we're going to cover today
is release engineering.
And so I just want to get
a quick show of hands.
For folks, when they think
about release engineering,
does Stackdriver come
to mind, or monitoring
in general come to mind,
as a forefront principal,
or a piece of
release engineering?
Show of hands, anyone?
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
I'm just saying,
I'm not putting my
hand for that one.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: OK.
So, looks like we got
about four or five people.
So looks like I have
some people to win over
as far as convincing
you all that Stackdriver
does play a very integral
role with release engineering
and, specifically, release
engineering in the way
that the SRE kind of
book defines it as.
So let's dive right into it.
So this is an actual
quote, so chapter 8.
For those of you who haven't
had the chance to comb
through the SRE book, chapter
8 covers release engineering
as a whole.
And so I think this ties back to
the initial kind of discussion
point that we had in that
first, second, or third slide,
talking about how, if we want
services to be more reliable,
it requires to invest upfront in
a reliable and, in my opinion,
standardized release processes.
It's essential that, when
we define these upfront,
that developers, SREs,
and release engineers
actually work together.
So talking about breaking
down those boundaries,
oftentimes, is investing
upfront in kind of deciding
what that process looks like.
And so a lot of that
has been kind of looped
into a lot of the buzzwords
of continuous delivery,
continuous CI/CD.
I think J. Paul Reed,
one of the DevOps days,
I think, in Atlanta, really
had my favorite definition
of continuous delivery.
And that's getting your
entire organization
to care about
release engineering,
and, I think, quality
assurance-- and he
goes on to say-- in a
way that it had never
cared about them before.
And so what we're
going to see here is,
we're going to talk about what
release engineering actually
means in the context of SRE.
And then we're going
to talk about how
quality assurance and
Stackdriver all kind of fit
into this picture.
so in chapter 8--
who knew these four
principles by heart?
No?
OK.
So we're going to talk about
what the SRE book kind of
defines release engineering as.
And it's really reliant
upon four key pillars.
And that's self-service model.
And I've tried to sum up in
kind of single-word summaries.
So that's being able to provide
automation to your teams.
So as we know break out into
this microservices world,
into this two-pizza-team
world, each of these,
without the investment in
release engineering upfront,
results in bespoke
processes that often--
especially, I see it in folks
as they start to transition
into Kubernetes, people fall
into the local optimum trap.
Everyone is writing their
own little automation,
fast scripts, what have you.
I'm guilty, too.
For all my demos, I don't
always use the tools
that I'm showing up here.
Sometimes, I'll just right Bash.
But ultimately, we want to
create a self-service model
for folks and for teams
to be able to adopt.
And I think there's a lot of
that in the higher-level SRE
principles of just
automating away toil.
I won't touch, too much, on high
velocity and hermetic builds.
But I think a lot
of this is being
able to tie immutable
infrastructure in Docker.
Folks expecting to-- if
I have a Docker file,
and have a
repository, this build
should behave the
same way no matter
where I'm running it from.
And also, just being able to,
rather than doing hot fixes,
and SSH-ing into the
machine, and just
trying to figure
out what's going on,
and making those changes,
being able to just tear away
infrastructure, and deploy
a brand-new resource,
and really treating my
infrastructure as immutable,
really tie in to these
middle-to-high velocity
and hermetic builds pillars.
But the last thing I'm
going to talk about
is the enforcement of
policies and procedures.
And so the I see this
is that a lot of folks--
and a lot of us get excited
about technology first.
And we get excited
about tools first.
But when it comes to the
pillars of release engineering,
oftentimes, we want to reflect
our own business processes
or compliance
processes that we're
held accountable for,
and the policies that
are specific to our culture, to
the way that our team actually
does things.
And so I kind of sum that
up as configurability.
So the two pillars of
release engineering
I'm going to focus in on is
automation and configurability.
Now, so for folks who kind of
take these words at face value,
it kind of seems like they don't
have a whole bunch in common.
I think the SRE book talks
about automating away
releases to the point
where engineers are only
needed if there are issues.
But that seems a little
bit different from folks
adopting configurability
to match,
whether it's shipping off
to specific business units
to perform kind of intense
tests or functional tests,
or being able to
basically introduce
these breakpoints where
automation is not possible,
so human approval processes.
Finding a sweet spot between
the two is often very difficult.
So we're going to try and do
that in the next five minutes.
So to solve that requires
an ops-centric, CI/CD kind
of approach.
So what I mean here is-- and
so here's just another warning.
If every team is
figuring out they're
own deployment
processes, you want
to avoid that
local optimum trap.
And we really want to
design for an ops-centric,
continuous-delivery pipeline.
So this is the ability to
have a single pane of glass,
to see how all of
your deployments
for different services
are progressing, and being
able to have that basic kind
of auditing trail of what
has been deployed, with
integrated monitoring.
And so this does require a
bit more management effort
compared to some of the
other kind of methods that
are outlined on this slide.
But it really is
worth it to achieve
that balance between
configurability and automation.
So let's actually take a
look at what that means.
And the context that we're
setting for this today
is utilizing a tool
called Spinnaker.
Can I get a show of hands
of who knows Spinnaker?
OK.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Oh.
Huh.
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Most of the room.
All right, now we're wading
into familiar territory.
And we'll also be talking
about how this fits together
with Stackdriver.
So Stackdriver, I think,
needs no introduction.
We've covered it in depth,
provides a holistic solution
across logging and monitoring.
And Spinnaker is an open source
continuous delivery tool,
again, really focused
on what happens
once you have an
artifact, and how can we
have Cloud-native APIs
to roll out things to VMs
or to Kubernetes itself.
So Spinnaker is an
open-source project.
I think it initially
got its fame Netflix.
But Google has contributed
to the project, as well.
So Spinnaker-- if
you're not familiar
with the basic
building blocks, I'm
just going to quickly
touch on them,
that we have the notion of
pipelines, stages, and tasks.
So these are things
that can define--
you'll see here in the sample
pipeline that we are triggered
off of a new image,
or a new version
of an image being pushed
to some type of registry.
I think if you were to
do this within Google,
you might set up
a Pub/Sub trigger
once something is pushed out
to Google Container Registry.
And then, from there, we may
have multiple different stages
that define, let's say,
a canary deployment,
or something like that.
So this pipeline is just
a sequence of actions.
So let's start with the common
pattern here that I think--
I've seen a lot of
customers that do experiment
with Spinnaker kind of take on.
And this is manual judgments.
So this is the ability,
within our pipelines,
to actually define a
human approval step.
This might be something
where QA is monitoring
in minutes or in hours.
And they're looking
at a dashboard
and to decide whether or not a
pipeline should move forward.
So I think an example is
folks looking at observability
across a canary deployment.
But I think-- and
I believe this is
a quote from
someone from Netflix
who blogged about
manual judgments.
And they talked
about, oftentimes,
it is just a poor
developer staring
at a whole bunch of
graphs in a dashboard,
or combing through structured
or unstructured logs,
and trying to figure
out whether they should
move forward or roll back.
And so the challenge
with this is, not only
do developers sometimes
find this boring--
some developers, not all.
But this is also
challenging at scale.
If we are deploying
more frequently,
and we are introducing
more microservices
into our environment, what
becomes the bottleneck?
Does release engineering
become the bottleneck
because every pipeline
requires someone
to watch a dashboard
for an hour?
At scale, it
becomes challenging.
If you are doing
this, again-- and
I'll talk about how we
would automate this away.
I do want to show, quickly,
that folks still do this.
And I think for folks getting
started with pipelines,
there's absolutely
nothing wrong with it.
So to define kind of what I
was discussing in that slide,
you'll see here that I have
an actual Spinnaker pipeline.
And what we're looking at is
this manual approval stage
that I have here.
So one of the things
that's really useful, even
if you're not able to
introduce automation yet,
or you're not running
into that scale issue
yet, what you can do is begin
to kind of seed Stackdriver
into this manual approval
process, or your release
engineering.
So what we're able to do--
oh, actually, I already
had that open.
So let's just take a look at it.
What we're actually able to
do is, within Metrics Explorer
in Stackdriver Monitoring,
we can look at our metrics
here, and actually
create filters,
or group-specific
metrics, and actually
create a dashboard with that.
So a fairly easy win, if
you're utilizing Spinnaker,
is to be able to
create custom charts
that you want folks
to be able to look
at for relevant metrics, to
help them make that decision,
if they should
approve a pipeline,
to move forward or not.
So what you'll see
here is that I actually
have this filter defined
for 500 Response Codes.
And we see how, if I deploy
a baseline in the canary
together, what
that actually looks
like as far as the new version
with new configuration,
and baseline, which is deployed
at the same time as canary
to mimic production.
And I don't want
to gloss over that.
But we can't spend
too much time.
The note is that it is helpful
to deploy a baseline if you are
taking on canary deployments
so that you can have
a fair comparison for the new
version of your application,
or your canary, to production.
And the reason that
that's important
is because the production
environment that's already
been deployed may already--
they may have already filled
a cache from the database.
And this is something
that a baseline
would have to do from
scratch, much like a canary.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
So the first thing
you're doing, before you
even introduce really
any automation, is
that you're basically
making that decision of whether
to move forward or roll back
standardized.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: That's right.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
You were saying,
instead of making a
subjective decision,
look at this dashboard.
Compare the thing.
If it looks good, move forward.
If not, look back.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Precisely.
I think that Spinnaker
frames it in that way,
to provide instructions
on this manual judgment.
And because we can embed
a very simple link here,
that we can create from
this Metrics Explorer chart,
it's really useful
to provide context
as far as what should be
observed for a specific service
or application that's
being deployed.
So that being said, if we
can introduce automation,
we want to.
So Spinnaker and Stackdriver,
as a combination,
allows for this, as well.
So what you're looking
at is an actual--
I should have noted that the
canary and bassline that I
was presenting is deployed
into a Kubernetes environment.
And so you'll see
here, this is sort
of what I was looking at
within that dashboard.
The baseline, we have a canary.
And both of these are actually
exporting Prometheus metrics
into Stackdriver.
And then we are led to a
place called Canary Analysis
and Kayenta in the diagram.
And so what are these?
So one thing you should
know about Spinnaker
is that it is a micro
service-based platform.
So Kayenta is one
of these services,
that is part of Spinnaker,
that provides automated canary
analysis.
And so what this means is
that, if we have metrics,
we can actually begin to create
automation where we define,
based on these
metrics, based on what
we're looking at for a
non-production, environment,
can we get a score?
And based on that score, should
that pipeline automatically
move forward?
So this is where Kayenta and
Stackdriver come into play.
Again, Kayenta is used to
automate this canary judgment.
And you can introduce
this as a stage
and you're Spinnaker pipeline.
It doesn't involve a human
operator to judge the releases.
We are distinctly taking
this from the metrics
that we are collecting
within Stackdriver.
So in the example today, we're
looking at the request metric
from Prometheus.
So if you are using
or standardizing
on a set of metrics, if you
can get them into Stackdriver,
you can build them into
this automated canary
analysis within your pipeline.
The last thing I'll note is that
you can group together metrics
and weight specific metrics if
there's several metrics that we
need to look at.
In my example, we have
a very simple example.
But I want to note,
there is the ability
to introduce complexity,
much like I'm sure you'll
find in your services, as well.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And
I should point out,
kind of referring back to our
first principle, talking SLOs,
with SLO monitoring, those
actually become available
as metrics in Stackdriver.
You can have Kayenta
use your SLO metrics,
and not just things
like error rates.
You can actually see
like what is my error
rate over a 30 minute
rolling window,
to be able to make those
judgments pretty quickly,
and make those judgments
off the same judgments
that you use to
determine whether or not
your actual service is healthy.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Precisely.
So what I'm showing
you here is we
have that very same
pipeline, except,
now, we actually have a
stage for canary analysis
where there was once
manual judgment.
And so what we see
here is, if we actually
look at what is configured
within this canary analysis
stage, is that we actually
are configuring metrics here.
And so you'll see here
that I only have one group.
So this is Group 1.
But we can actually create
multiple groups of metrics
and then assign each of
those a score as far as
how those should be weighted
in this canary-analysis stage.
So you'll see here
that, again, I'm
going off of the actual error
code here, which is 500.
If we see an
increase in that, we
should expect the
pipeline to fail.
And so what is really good about
that is that we can now, again,
for Spinnaker pipelines
that don't kind of, I guess,
yield any distinct, or
useful, or new information
about your application
or your service,
we now no longer have to insert
a human there to, let's say,
monitor a dashboard for 30
minutes, or for an hour,
to come back to it.
And then, even from
there, to make a decision
that isn't necessarily
standardized.
Now, we can provide
automation where needed so
that, if we do have
a set of metrics
where we can define
this threshold,
we can introduce this
using Spinnaker, Kayenta,
and Stackdriver.
So The last thing I want to
note is that, whether or not
you're able to automate
this process, I think,
is an open question
for a lot of folks.
Again, and a lot of it will have
to match sort of what approval
processes you require today.
But regardless of whether
there's manual approval
or automation, one thing I
think folks can adopt and get
a quick win, as far as
Spinnaker and Stackdriver,
is actually monitoring
with context,
and what I mean by
that is actually
being able to utilize the notion
of a counter for a Spinnaker
deployments, or events from
Spinnaker, and overlay that
on the performance
of your application.
And so the way that we actually
have this, an example here.
And actually let me
talk through it first.
And we'll look at the demo.
Orca is-- again, as I
mentioned, Spinnaker
is based on a set
of microservices.
So Orca is the workflow engine.
And Orca actually
emits events to Echo
so what we can actually do is
configure Echo to basically--
we can provide an external URL
to actually get these events.
So this might be a Spinnaker
pipeline being created.
This might be a specific
stage being complete.
We can actually use something
like Google Cloud Functions,
or anything that has
an external endpoint,
and actually write that into
Stackdriver using the Logging
Client Library.
So what we're able to do here
, is we can configure Echo
in Spinnaker to basically write
these events to a Google com
function, which will then write
that into that Stackdriver
Logging.
So it's actually,
look at that, we
can see here that I have a
whole bunch of different logs
in Stackdriver
Logging that actually
signify some of these events
that Orca is emitting.
And what we can
actually do here--
and I haven't done this
in preparation for this.
But we actually can create a
log-based metric that actually
counts for something specific.
So if a pipeline was
successful, let's
actually create a
logs-based metric
based on a filter for
that specific log.
So this is something
where, now, we can then,
in Metrics Explorer, if
we were to create this,
create a dashboard that
provides that context of,
this deployment happened, and
we're looking at all of these,
let's say, error
response codes over time.
So again, kind of marrying
the two concepts of automation
and configurability,
definitely not an easy task.
But I do believe that there is a
good story, if you're utilizing
Spinnaker to integrate
Stackdriver within that,
to implement the both of these
pillars of release engineering
as defined by the SRE book.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah.
So I think you showed us three
really interesting things
there.
The first one is just to
include Stackdriver charts
in your Spinnaker
manual judgments.
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
An opinion on that.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah,
it's super useful.
Because it actually gives folks
a sort of a standardized way
to make those judgments.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: That's right.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And
then you showed us
how to actually do
automation off those metrics.
So have, that pipeline
make the decision,
or have Spinnaker
make that decision
based on those metrics.
And finally,
actually use the data
that's coming out of Spinnaker
to inform you even better,
to really understand how
performance or availability is
impacted by deployment events.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: That's right.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
All right, cool.
So let's review the three
principles we've covered today.
We started out by talking
about error budgets and SLOs.
And kind of the big
takeaway is, there,
that, one, you should use them.
They're really good.
And two, is that
Stackdriver now,
with the announcement of
Anthos and the Anthos Service
Mesh this week, allows
you to actually do
proper SLO monitoring.
So you should absolutely
configure SLO monitoring
in Stackdriver.
Then we talked
about observability
and how to use Stackdriver
to collect the golden signals
from your services
and combine them
into a single
place for analysis.
And then, finally, we talked
about actually including
Stackdriver data as an input
in your release engineering
practices, specifically, how do
you evaluate canary judgments
using Stackdriver metrics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]